>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Good afternoon, everyone,
and thank you for being here.
On behalf of the chief
of the Hispanic division,
Dr. Georgette Dorn, I would
like to welcome you all
to this very special event
with saxophonist, composer
and educator, Miguel Zenon.
I am joined by my colleague from
the music division Larry Applebaum
who is senior music reference
specialist in the music division.
I am Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
and I am a reference librarian
and music librarian specialist
in the Hispanic division.
Miguel Zenon was born and raised on
the beautiful island of Puerto Rico,
where he attended Le
Universidad es Musica.
He received his bachelor's degree
in jazz studies at Berkeley College
of Music and a master's
degree in jazz performance
from the Manhattan School of Music.
But as we know, musicians test their
chops collaborating with others.
And the list of musicians
Miguel has collaborated
with is quite impressive.
I will not name them all of course,
but they include Charlie Hayden,
David Sanchez, Gear McKlein, the
Jeff Ballard Trio, Steve Coleman
and Dominguez Band
among many others.
He has been a [inaudible]
in nearly 80 recordings.
15 of those recordings have been
with the award-winning
band SF Jazz Collective,
of which Miguel is one
of the founding members.
Miguel has also led his
own quartet for 15 years
and has recorded ten albums, all
received with the highest praise
by the press and the public,
starting with Looking Forward
in 2002, selected by
the New York Times
as the number one alternative
jazz album of the year.
His latest album, Typical, was
released this year in February.
I want to highlight just a couple
of things from Miguel's outstanding
and impressive career
at such a young age.
And we'll get to talk about
many others in our conversation.
Miguel is the recipient
of a fellowship
from the John Simon
Guggenheim Foundation
which supported the recording
of Esta Blena, hailed by critics
in the US and Puerto Rico as one
of the best recordings of 2009.
It also received two
Grammy nominations,
one for best improvised solo and one
for best jazz recording of the year,
as well as a Latin Grammy nomination
for best Latin jazz
recording of the year.
Miguel was again nominated
for a Grammy award in 2012
for best large jazz ensemble album.
And another Latin Grammy award
for best instrumental album
for Alma Alventro, the Puerto
Rican Songbook, which pays tribute
to the compositions and
explorers of music of some
of the great Puerto Rican composers,
[inaudible], Pedro Flores,
Rafael Hernandez and
Silvia [inaudible].
And is my personal favorite album.
His ninth album, Identities
are Changeable,
also received a Grammy award
nomination in 2014 and was hailed
by critics as one of the best
jazz recordings of the year.
Besides being an accomplished
musician and composer,
Miguel is also an educator and
is a permanent faculty member
of the New England
Conservatory of Music.
He has also taught and led
workshops around the world,
including the Bounce Center,
[inaudible], the Conservatory
of Paris, among many others.
In 2003 he was chosen by the
Kennedy Center to teach and perform
in West Africa as part of
their jazz ambassadors program.
And since 2011 he has led
the program [Spanish name]
in Puerto Rico and will be
talking about that briefly.
In 2008, Miguel received the
prestigious MacArthur Fellowship,
also known as the Genius
Grant, for --
and I quote from the
Fellowship's page --
"For expanding the boundaries
of Latin and jazz music
through his elegant and
innovative musical collages.
In his work as a saxophonist
and a composer,
Zenon demonstrates an astonishing
mastery of old and new jazz mediums,
from African American and Latin
American rhythmic concepts
to free avant garde jazz."
Miguel, welcome to the
Library of Congress
and thank you for being here.
>> Miguel Zenon: Thank you.
It's great to be here, Talia.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
For today's event I will be
asking Miguel a couple questions,
and my colleague Larry
will be asking some others.
We'll have an opportunity of Q
and A and there's a special treat
of Miguel playing for
us today as well.
So we're in for a good time.
So recently, Kevin Whitehead
reviewed Typical on Fresh Air,
and he introduced you
with the following words.
He said, "There are lots of sides
to Zenon's music that only begin
with a complex insider/outside
status
of the Puerto Rican jazz musician."
So I would like to know what
drew you to sax as an instrument?
And considering the music landscape
in Puerto Rico in the 1980's
and 1990's, what drew
you to jazz specifically?
>> Miguel Zenon: Well like you
mentioned, I went to [Spanish name]
which is a performing arts
middle school and high school
in the capital of Puerto Rico.
I went there for six years.
And when I first started
studying there, I kind of went
in with the idea that I just wanted
to play an instrument, you know.
I didn't really have a
particular instrument in mind.
For some reason I was
attracted to the piano.
When I got there I was
about 11 years old.
But when I got there the first
day and you were involved
on your instrument, everybody got
the same idea as I did of course.
And all the piano spaces were taken.
So I had to choose something
else and I think the options were
like oboe, bassoon,
guitar and saxophone.
And I think there was
someone in my family
who had a saxophone lying around.
It just kind of made sense
out of all those instruments.
I was like, "Yeah, it
kind of makes sense.
Maybe saxophone."
And of course it eventually
grew on me.
But at first I was more attracted
to the idea of being able
to play any instrument, not really
an instrument in particular.
I was just attracted
to music in general.
And I went to that
school for six years.
It was all classical training,
so there was no jazz at
the school obviously.
I was exposed to a lot of
popular music and dance music.
And some of my early experience
as a professional musician
was when I was about 14, 15.
We were playing salsa music,
you know, dance music.
So that was kind of my early
introduction to playing something
that wasn't like chamber music.
And then eventually
towards the end of my period
of school I discovered jazz through
friends in the school passing
around tapes and talking about you
know, so and so and Charlie Parker.
It could be a Latin
American musician
like Pachito Rivera
or someone like that.
And I was really curious about the
idea of improvisation at the time,
because I had never been
exposed to anything like that,
or had any formal kind of training.
But I was really curious about it.
What did it for me at the time
was hearing Charlie parker play.
The first time I heard
him I was blown away,
not only because he played the same
instrument I played and he played it
with such an amazing facility
and great technical ability
and dexterity, et cetera.
But when I realized that he was
improvising, I was blown away.
Because I was like,
"How can you do that
and still play the
instrument that way?"
You know, such an amazing facility.
So I kind of became in a good
way obsessed about trying
to understand what these
musicians were doing.
Discovery jazz music changed my life
because even though I had been
studying music for a certain amount
of years at the school, I was
never like really serious about it.
You know, I never really considered
the possibility of being a musician.
You know, I was interested
in other things.
I was attracted to the natural
sciences and other things.
I was probably going to
follow that road somehow.
But discovering jazz, it really made
me passionate about music, you know?
And I had something I wanted
to understand and discover.
And from that point on, you know,
it just became a goal of mine
and I just kind of embarked on that
trip, you know, ever since then.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: I'm
sure you would have been a great
scientist, but I'm
glad you chose the sax.
Puerto Rican culture plays a central
role in your compositions, right?
And in a way it is an archive of our
musical traditions, [Spanish name].
And at the same time it's a
laboratory where you experiment
with combinations of sounds and
rhythms to create something new.
What compelled you to develop this
concept in your own compositions?
>> Miguel Zenon: Yes,
so that process was also
something that came later.
I mean, after I got really
interested in jazz and I realized
that jazz at least at that
time was not something
that I could pursue in Puerto Rico.
There were no higher education
institutions at the time
where I could study jazz.
So I had to go somewhere else.
And Berkeley in Boston
at the time made sense.
So I ended up going to Berkeley.
And when I got to Berkeley,
I realized fairly quickly
that I was lacking a lot in terms
of sort of like the language
of the jazz style if
you will, you know.
So I had a lot of work to do.
And I concentrated on really
trying to play jazz well, you know,
studying the music, transcribing,
listening, all the things
that musicians do, you know,
like immerse yourself
in a style of music.
And I wasn't writing any music and I
wasn't thinking about anything else
that wasn't jazz music for
about two or three years.
About the time that I graduated
Berkeley I started writing a little
music and kind of started to think
about what it was that I wanted,
if I wrote music, what it was
my music would sound like.
I realized that all this
effort that I had put in it
to study jazz music
was not something
that I had done with
Puerto Rican music.
I realized that I knew jazz music
better than Puerto Rican music
because I had studied the
history in a more systematic way.
You know, I grew up in Puerto Rico,
so I knew the sound of the music,
but I couldn't explain it to
somebody else if they asked me.
So I decided that I wanted
to be able to do that,
and I sort of like again just
went into this kind of like --
treating it almost like
a research project.
Saying, "Okay, what is
this style of music?
Where did it come from?
What is it's history?
Different dimensions,
how deep is the family?
Et cetera, et cetera."
And as I would go into this style
of music or elements of culture
or folklore, et cetera, a lot
of those sounds started finding
their way into some of the music
that I was starting to write.
And as I did it more and more, I
realized that I would get a lot more
from the research if I just
focused on one theme, you know.
So you plan your music
or some of the others.
So a lot of my recording projects
were born out of this interest
to understand Puerto Rican music
and Puerto Rico better,
just for my own sake.
And I also feel that it
just kind of helped me.
I mean, I've been living
in the United States
for about 20 something years
now, so it helps me connect
to Puerto Rico from afar.
It helped me find a connection to my
side of what made me a Puerto Rican
and connected to my country
that we use in the music.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
That's very interesting
about the connections to the island,
because your recording from 2014,
Identities are Changeable,
explores precisely those links
that the diaspora has
with the island
and how we define what
it is to be Puerto Rican.
Could you share with us how you
approached this project and the role
that the Puerto Rican communities
in Puerto Rico and the US played?
And what inspired you?
How did they inspire
you to create it?
>> Miguel Zenon: Yeah, so Identities
are Changeable was a project
that was born out of again
just curiosity or me trying
to understand a side of what
it means to be Puerto Rican.
And like I said, I've been living
in the States for a long time,
mostly in the New York City area.
I have family in New York, like
many of us Puerto Ricans do.
And I've experienced sort of
firsthand this idea of second
and third generation Puerto
Ricans outside of Puerto Rico.
And this kind of role that exists,
you know, with Puerto Ricans outside
of Puerto Rico, et cetera.
So I was really curious about
what this experience was like,
because this experience was
not my experience, you know.
And I wanted to understand
it better.
So what I decided to do was --
this all came out of an initiative,
a commission from Walker University
when they first approached me.
Okay, so now I can do this thing.
And what I decided to do was
interview a series of individuals,
all second or third generation
Puerto Ricans born and raised in
or around the New York City area.
That was kind of my first step.
I just wanted to talk to them about
their experience, about you know,
how they felt as Puerto
Ricans or New Yorkers or both,
and their identity in general.
And as I went through the interviews
and the questions of getting people
to join the project, I started
to think that what I wanted
to do was use the interviews, like
clips from the interviews basically,
something to lace with the music.
So they kind of give their voice,
like a musical identity
almost, like a solo.
So that's what I ended
up doing on the project.
I was very new to this whole
idea of trying to combine music
with some other kind
of multimedia platform.
But I think ultimately what I
ended up getting from the project,
not only in terms of
information for myself,
but trying to understand this
idea better, was that I was able
to think very differently
about this idea
of a what a national identity
means to us as Puerto Ricans,
and Puerto Ricans both on the
island and outside of the island.
And of course I would say
probably 10 years ago I had a very
narrow-minded definition
of what this is.
And now after going
through this project I think
about it pretty much
totally differently.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Besides your permanent position
in the New England School of Music
and the workshops and seminars
that you teach around the world, you
also have a project in Puerto Rico
since 2011 called [Spanish name],
which in a way sort of gives you
that other leg, you know.
One leg here in the
US and the other leg
in Puerto Rico with that project.
Could you tell us a
little bit about that?
>> Miguel Zenon: Yeah, definitely.
So [Spanish name] is a project
that was born out of an interest
of trying to use in this case
jazz music because it's what I do
as a platform to sort of preach the
importance of culture in society.
And how these sort of cultural
nativities that are very --
you know, they're not at least to
my eyes simple things, you know.
Music and art and all those
things should be available
to everyone, you know.
And I feel that a lot of
places around the world
that have done this
really well have done this
with a great amount of success.
So I've always had this idea in mind
of taking jazz music and taking it
to places where it's not you know --
where people are not as accustomed
to seeing it or having it around
and just giving them the
opportunity to be exposed.
You know, I don't really see it as
a way of commercializing the music
or opening up the gap to
one audience or anything.
I just feel like it's important
for people to be exposed to as much
as possible and let them decide
if this stuff is for them or not.
So this idea became the reality in
part with the help of this injection
of funds from the MacArthur
Foundation.
In 2011 like you mentioned,
we started putting
together these concerts.
What we do is pretty simple.
We put together a free of charge
jazz concert in the rural areas
of Puerto Rico, so everything
outside of the metropolitan areas
of San Juan and surrounding areas.
And each concert is focused on a
specific historical jazz figure,
be it Miles Davis, John Coltrane,
Charles Parker, et cetera.
I mean, the locations of course,
we've been all over the place.
We've been to [inaudible]
and some of those places too.
And they vary from theater to
school theaters to you know --
I think we did one at the Lion's
Club with everybody, you know.
But that's a part of the idea.
We use what the community
has at its disposal
and we have [inaudible]
and people come out.
So it's a mixed crowd, you know,
from kids to older
people and families.
It's been great.
So a part of the thing we do
is we put together the concert.
Before the concert we'll do a
pre-concert talk where we talk
about the history of jazz.
We talk about sort of the basic
concepts of improvisation.
So we give people sort
of like a perspective
of what they're about to hear.
Because most of the people, I would
say of all the concerts we do,
about 75% of the public have never
been to a jazz concert before.
So we try to give them
a little perspective.
We talk about the music of a chosen
composer, you know, be it Miles
or -- we talk about their
life, their history, et cetera.
And then we do the concert and
we always finish the concert
by incorporating a group of
young students from the community
and that's always of course
the climax of the thing.
Because not only you get
to kind of like pass this
on to a younger generation of
young musicians who are interested
in getting out there, but also
I feel that it's important
that these communities feel that
they're part of the project.
That it's not just us coming
in and playing and leaving,
but they're adding something to it.
And just a couple years ago
we started giving out little
like scholarships, like
a little grant to one
of the students that plays.
So we give them a little money
so they can buy instruments
or take lessons and et cetera.
And I think we've had
maybe 11 or 12 concerts.
I can't remember.
But I would definitely say
that this has been the most --
at least to me -- the
most rewarding experience
that I've been in with music.
You know, this idea of just
putting these concerts together,
not thinking about ticket sales,
not thinking about
publicity or anything.
Just go play.
And it's probably back to this
idea of the purity of the art form,
the purity of music and just
being able to get there, play,
connecting with someone
and have them just enjoy it
for the sake of music.
For me it's been super rewarding.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: Would
you say then that [Spanish name] --
to me at least, I see it as a
vehicle that shows how music
and culture in general
is fundamental
to everyone's daily life, right?
And the people in those communities
that see it also have a
right to this for sure.
Would you say that music education
is essential to the development also
of a sense of citizenship
or commitment to something?
>> Miguel Zenon: Yeah,
I totally feel that way.
I think especially these days,
this idea of having music
and just artistic expression around
us, especially as we're growing up,
when we're young, I think
it's not given the importance
that it should be.
And just kind of going back to
my education in Puerto Rico,
and I went to a fine arts
school and became a musician.
But a lot of my peers
did not, you know.
They became scientists and baseball
players and all kinds of stuff.
But when I see them now, I
feel we have this connection
because they went through
the process of seeing music
from the inside, you know,
as performers and learning
to play an instrument and getting
through this artistic
expression even if it's something
that they're not going to use
as a way of making a living.
It changed them, you know.
And I feel that it's so important
to give everyone, as many people
as we can, the opportunity
to go through the process
of seeing what it feels
to create something
from an artistic point of view.
And I think that's
why it's so important
to have this available
and have this out there.
And I'm a firm believer in this.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
In your webpage --
which I encourage you all to visit.
It's pretty interesting.
You have a section
of other interests,
and you're into literature.
Which gives us a glimpse into
you know, your broad interest
in other cultural things.
Could you tell us what
role literature played
in your music, if any?
You have a recording also
called [Spanish name],
which is pretty unique.
>> Miguel Zenon: Yeah, well
you know, I do enjoy reading.
I mean, it's something that I
just enjoy for the sake of it,
like I like listening to
music and everything else.
This project, as you mentioned,
was unique in its own way
because what I did was I focused
on this [inaudible] book along
with this friend of mine from Paris.
And it just kind of made
sense because that's kind
of like what the book
jumps back, from Paris.
We're trying to put something
together and that book just happened
to be like the perfect
sort of platform.
And it just happens
to be my favorite.
So we tackled it in a way that
we used the book as inspiration
to write pieces and
et cetera, et cetera.
But it's not something that
I usually do, you know.
I don't usually think about
music that way, meaning --
let me see how to say this.
When I write music or when
I'm thinking about music,
I don't rely as much
on random inspiration.
And I deal with music more in a
step by step kind of systematic way,
where when I write something or
when I'm practicing I already kind
of have a set of materials or
tools that I already have with me.
So even though there
always is some improvisation
and of course some randomness,
I try to rely very little
on that aspect of it.
So in that sense if I'm reading a
book, it's very rare that I'm going
to write a piece of music based
on how that book made me feel.
It's going to be more likely that
I'm going to take a paragraph
and try to translate that
to musical terms somehow
and then write it more
from that perspective.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: And I have
one last question before we move
to Larry's portion.
I want to ask something about
Typical, which is your recent album.
I saw the album cover and
I read the word typical
which could be translated
to folk music in a sense.
And it's not exactly that, right?
When you listen, it's not
typical music in any sense.
So why that title?
Why Typical?
And how is this term used in
this project specifically?
>> Miguel Zenon: So the title
came from this idea of --
like you say, when
we as Puerto Ricans
or Latin Americans here this
word typical, or musica typica,
it usually means something
with folklore.
Something down to earth, you
know, earthy kind of thing.
And when I was thinking about this
and I was thinking about the meaning
and what it means, I started
thinking about how this at least
to my eyes could mean a style
of music that's connected
with a very specific
group of people.
Like Musica Typica from Puerto Rico.
Then you have typica from Cuba
and everybody has their
own kind of way about it.
You can break it up into
different sub-genres and all that.
And this recording
specifically, I was writing music
that was inspired pretty
much directly by my quartet
and the members of the quartet.
And I was thinking about
you know, writing pieces
that represent our sound
and represent you know,
like how we perform as a band and
this sort of like this language
that we've created together so we
can communicate with each other.
And I felt that that was
kind of our music, you know.
And Typical in this
case comes from that.
You know the title comes
from something saying,
"This is our sound.
This is the music that
sort of represents us."
And the cover is a great
picture, which is from here.
And I usually go through this
process of trying to pick a cover
and really getting to historical
pictures, actually those
that are connected to
Puerto Rico somehow.
And I found this great
picture by [inaudible].
And then going through the
filters, I found out it was here.
And the process was
actually really simple.
And it just worked out perfectly.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: Thank you.
Well I'm going to pass
the mic to you, Larry.
Thank you.
>> Larry Applebaum: I
like those questions.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez: Thank you.
>> Larry Applebaum: And
of course the answers.
I have many questions to ask,
but even before we start those,
I want to show you something
and get your reaction to it.
Let me put down the water.
I want you to describe
what you're seeing.
>> Miguel Zenon: Well,
maybe if I read it.
>> Larry Applebaum: This
is one of the treasures
from our collection
in the music division.
>> Miguel Zenon: This
is Barbados, right?
>> Larry Applebaum: Right.
>> Miguel Zenon: But it's
got a different title.
>> Larry Applebaum: Right.
>> Miguel Zenon: What's the title?
>> Larry Applebaum: Kangaroo.
So this is in the hand
of Charlie Parker.
>> Miguel Zenon: Oh my God,
this is something else.
You know, it's funny you show me
this, because there's this rumor
that goes around in music.
I've heard it a couple times
that Charlie didn't know how
to notate music and he wasn't
musically like trained,
like he just played
everything by ear and all that.
And I'm always like, "Man, it's
impossible he can play that way."
And it's great to see this.
You know, it's amazing.
Let me see if I'm getting
the notes right.
[ Humming ]
Well this is something else.
>> Larry Applebaum: Yeah.
>> Miguel Zenon: I'm
glad to see that.
>> Larry Applebaum:
So I'm curious --
because you mentioned
Charlie Parker earlier.
When you listen to an
improvising saxophonist
or any creative musician,
what are you listening for?
>> Miguel Zenon: Well,
that's a good question.
You know, as an instrumentalist
and someone that spends a lot
of time playing an instrument,
it's hard for me to disconnect
from listening to music from
that perspective, you know?
So usually if I hear
someone playing,
especially if they're playing
jazz, if they're playing any music,
I'm pretty much hearing chords and
notes and rhythm you know, first.
That's usually the
first thing I hear.
What keys it's on,
what notes are playing,
what's the beat, what's the feel.
You know, that kind of stuff.
But the music that I find
usually attractive in terms
of if I'm listening to an improviser
for example, or someone that's kind
of from a jazz perspective, I'm
attracted to personality in sound.
And that's something
that I work on myself.
And I've always been really
interested on this idea
that the instrument is a
reflection of our personality
and it's a reflection of
the way our bodies move.
And because I'm an instrumentalist
I know how hard it is to attain
and get to a point where
you get that instrument
to really be an extension of you.
So when I hear Charlie Parker
or [inaudible] musicians
in that category and I hear
the personality in their sound,
that's the first thing
that brings me
in before what they actually
are playing, you know.
And then, again I'm really
just saying this specifically
about jazz music.
I'm listening to a
connection to the evolution
of the tradition of jazz, you know.
What connection do they have to
the evolution of the language.
And again, I think I might
have mentioned this before,
but when I think about jazz music --
when I first started getting into
music I realized fairly quickly
that this was a language
first of all.
And second that it
wasn't my language.
So I had to kind of learn it
from scratch, much like learning
to speak English in a way, you know?
So when I hear players, be it
older or more modern players,
I'm listening for that connection.
And it's easier for me to relate to
someone that has a deeper connection
or something that I can hear more
clearly than someone that doesn't.
You know, so if I hear
that connection,
in some way it's easier
for me to relate.
>> Larry Applebaum: So
language is one thing.
I want to ask you about sound,
specifically your sound on the horn.
When we learn to speak, we're not
necessarily conscious of the sound
of our voice, the spoken voice.
But I wonder, how conscious
is your sound on your horn?
>> Miguel Zenon: Well, I
like to think about this
in sort of like two ways.
One way is the personality
thing that I mentioned before,
where we're really trying to portray
something that's unique to us.
And it's like it might be
inspired by someone you admire,
like in my case Charlie Parker and
Coltrane or somebody that I like.
And probably my sound is going to
be some kind of combination of that,
or try to be a combination of that
and other things that I like too.
So that's one side of it.
But in my opinion that's sort
of like the easier side of it.
The harder part is really
being able to connect
to the instrument physically.
And as an instrumentalist, a lot
of the things that we do and most
of the time that we spend
on the instrument is trying
to make this connection as
natural and seamless as possible.
That takes a lot of time of course.
And at least myself, I don't feel
that when I pick up the instrument,
the saxophone, it's not something
that my body is naturally
instructed to do.
You know, I have to
train myself to be able
to actually produce a
sound and a quality sound.
So I have to use parts of my
body when I play the saxophone
and use them in a very specific way.
And I use them in a way that I
don't use doing anything else,
doing my daily routine.
I have to use my diaphragm
in a very specific way,
use my lungs in a very specific
way, the muscles in my face
and my oral cavity and my throat.
That all adds to that
idea of just being able
to produce a sound, like one note.
So to me it's a balance between this
physical, almost like an athlete,
fitness kind of thing where you
really need to be fit and in shape
in order to be able to
produce quality sound.
And then once you can control
that, then you try to bring
to that sound personality.
And like I said, this
could take forever.
This could take forever.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Was there a point
at which you felt you had
finally arrived at your own sound?
Your own musical identity?
>> Miguel Zenon: There was
definitely a point where I felt
that I was in the right direction,
that I felt that I had
found something that worked
and I just kind of needed
to finesse it a little bit.
>> Larry Applebaum: There's a
mysterious process especially
for jazz players, because so much of
what they do involves improvisation.
So here's one of my questions, is
how did you learn to improvise?
>> Miguel Zenon: Okay.
So one thing about improvisation
that's important to understand --
and this is something again
that helped me immensely --
was to understand the
difference between improvisation
as a general concept and
improvisation within a language
or within a musical
language in this case.
Like for example, when I was in
Puerto Rico and I was listening
and mostly playing salsa music
and listening to that music,
the language that I
was using to improvise
within that music was very different
than the language I would play
if I was playing Barbados
or Kangaroo.
The music is a different language.
I'm improvising in
both cases, you know,
but using a different language.
Again, kind of going back to
this idea of English and Spanish,
I might be saying the same thing
but using a different language
and improvising, et cetera.
So once that became clear to me,
the next step for me was, okay,
so I want to improvise but I don't
have enough language in this case.
So I need to acquire more language.
So I do that by listening, by
transcribing, my immersing myself
in this language, in this
case in the jazz language.
And as I get myself more and
more immersed in this language,
a lot of these things that you
know Charlie Parker played,
or Corbin Hawk or Alyssa
Young or whoever I like.
And I check that and I
was influenced by it.
It starts as something that you
basically repeat, repetition.
And then it eventually
just becomes second nature.
You internalize it and
it becomes part of you.
And the combinations of all
these players eventually becomes
your personality.
Along with your own ideas.
I think there's a point where you --
at least for myself there was
a point where I started to look
at a Charlie Parker
composition or solo and instead
of necessarily repeating
what he played,
I would sort of analyze
what he played.
And say, "Okay, so if he did
this this way on this chorus
with this rhythm and these notes,
that means that I can turn it around
and do it differently, or
take a couple more steps."
And you start building
your language on the idea
of addition and assimilation.
And then eventually you use
that language to improvise.
So I see it more as
improvisation is not necessarily --
in this case jazz improvisation
is not where you just go up
and play whatever comes
to your mind.
But it's sort of like an
organized improvisation.
You're improvising on ideas based on
information that you've already got.
And you're using that
information to improvise.
>> Larry Applebaum: I can hear that
you are a somewhat analytic person.
Are you self-critical?
>> Miguel Zenon: Yeah.
Yeah, you could say that too.
[Laughs].
>> Larry Applebaum: So when you're
listening to your own music,
or really for any kind of music,
what do you think makes a good solo?
>> Miguel Zenon: Well, I
think it's a little different
when I'm listening to myself and
when I'm listening to someone else,
especially if it's
somebody that I admire.
Someone like [inaudible]
and Coltrane and all those.
You know, a lot of those solos,
I listen to them differently
because they forge
something like what I play.
So it's harder for
me to be critical.
But with myself, and
a lot of my friends
and me do this all the time --
where I record a concert
and I go listen back.
And I say, "Okay, maybe this works
and that doesn't work, you know,
from a perspective of performance."
It's also perspective of just
like a player, or you know,
when I'm naturally
playing and improvising.
And I'm listening for things as
basic as time, you know, intonation,
sound, to interaction
with other musician.
You know, am I reacting to what's
around me, or am I just kind
of going blindly and on
my own kind of space?
And I'm also trying to find when
I listen back to it at least,
I'm trying to find like a
connecting sort of thread
through the improvised solo.
And I'm trying to find
something that --
you know, you hear this all
the time, tells the story.
It's kind of that, but it's more --
I like to think about it
more from the perspective of,
am I paying enough attention
not only to what's around me,
but am I paying enough
attention to what I'm playing
so that I'm not just
sort of rambling
and I can actually use the
ideas I'm putting out there
to build something
that's logical and basic?
>> Larry Applebaum: You teach also.
Can you teach someone to swing?
>> Miguel Zenon: I think so.
I mean, it's not going
to be the kind of thing
where it's going to
take five minutes.
But I think you can do it.
>> Larry Applebaum:
How would you do it?
>> Miguel Zenon: I think
it's like anything.
I think that kind of
thing has to do with --
it's almost like learning an accent,
like if you're speaking a language
and learning an accent, you know.
Like I was somewhere the other day
and someone told me I had a New York
accent and I was blown away by that.
I was like, "Really?
A New York accent?
I've never even thought
about that before."
But it's almost like if
you're teaching someone
to learn a British accent
or something like that.
It kind of is -- the
only way you can do
that is by immersion, you know.
By just listening and playing along
and listening and playing along.
And a lot of times what I end up
saying, when I hear someone play,
like a drummer or a pianist and
I'm talking about slow swing
for example, and I will say like
your swing feel is too straight
or it's too exaggerated and so on.
Sometimes it's too
much on the other side.
So I would say something like that.
So I would say, "Okay, so your
swing feel is too straight.
So why don't you check out
so and so and so and so,
who's going to pull
you to the other side?"
And if it's too much of the other
side, then I'm going to say, "Okay,
so you should be listening to
this, this, this and this."
You know, just immersion and
listening and transcription
and trying to find your
place with what you lay.
I mean, a lot of what we do as
jazz musicians is trying to prove
to ourselves in the place
of musicians we admire.
So we play along with records.
You know, we play along with
records to try to see if I'm going
to play a [inaudible]
solo or a Coltrane solo.
I'm going to put that record on
and I'm going to learn that solo,
and I'm going to try to phrase
it exactly the same way.
I'm going to try to pull things
through the same exact articulation.
And in that sense we're not only
getting to the notes and the theory
of it, but the actual feel.
So a lot of what we do in
terms of learning and feel,
be it learning how to swing
in jazz, or just learning how
to make the music feel good,
is by emulating what's
out there, you know.
>> Larry Applebaum: Talia
was mentioning not just your
accomplishments, but the awards
you've received over the years.
And I wonder, is recognition
important to you?
>> Miguel Zenon: Well I like to
think about it from a perspective
of it's something that's
important in terms
of opening doors to opportunities.
I mean,
I definitely feel like things
like the MacArthur Fellowship
and the Guggenheim
Fellowship, Grammy nominations,
all those things, they give myself
and my music more visibility
and opens doors professionally.
Which makes me work more
and makes my life easier.
But on the other hand, like you
said, I'm self-critical and I'm sort
of a firm believer on
being my own judge.
I believe that I'm the
person that's most capacitive
to really accurately say what
it is that I'm doing wrong
and what I'm not doing well.
>> Larry Applebaum: As a
judge, are you forgiving?
>> Miguel Zenon: Yeah, sure.
I mean, it's the kind of thing --
I'm not going to be
totally flagellating myself
or anything over a solo.
But I take recognition of these kind
of awards as something that's good.
But even if it was
something that was negative,
like even if it was a
review, a negative review
or a positive review, to me
those things are basically
at the end of the day opinions.
And they will have effect, like
this opinion and that opinion.
But at the end of the day, I'm
working sort of based on the amount
of effort and the amount of
work that I still need to do.
I mean, I always feel that there's
always something I can do better.
And it's probably just the way
it's going to be, and that's kind
of how I do it with my work.
>> Larry Applebaum: You
never stop learning.
>> Miguel Zenon: No.
That's right.
>> Larry Applebaum: So you
mentioned Charlie Parker
and I know how important
his music is to you.
If he were here with us
today, what would you
like to ask him or
talk to him about?
>> Miguel Zenon: I would probably
ask him about what he's practicing.
It's funny you say that,
because there's this interview
with Paul Desmond,
who I'm sure you know.
It blows me away every
time I hear it,
because Paul Desmond was
a great saxophonist too.
He was asked about his playing.
And I'm thinking this is probably
like late-40's, early-'50's
and this music was so new that
you know, to hear someone play
that way is almost like someone
inventing a whole new language
within a period of like two years,
and then that language becoming it,
like what everybody
wanted to play like.
And then it was like
the greatest thing.
And still now I hear
it and I'm like, "Wow,
this is the greatest thing ever."
You know, and on the interview
he's talking to Charlie Parker
about his practice routine.
And it blew me away what
Charlie Parker was talking about,
how much he practiced.
At some point he said, "I might
be practicing 10-11 hours a day."
But a lot of what he was
practicing were things
that were really basic things.
You know, scales, time,
just assimilating solos.
So I'm always interested
in how you know,
musicians build their routines, you
know, build their routines and build
on things that are
important to them, you know.
So I would probably
ask him something
about his practice routine.
>> Larry Applebaum: I'm very
curious what your questions will be.
And you'll have a chance to
ask them in just a moment.
I'll ask one last one, and that is,
as a musician, composer, arranger,
educator, as a father, how
do you measure success?
>> Miguel Zenon: It's hard to say.
I mean, I think probably
the way I would do it --
and this is kind of how I
think about this in general.
When I started playing this music
and when I decided that I wanted
to be a musician for a living, I did
it because my goal was to be able
to play with people I
admired, you know, my heroes.
And I've gotten to do that
a bunch over the years
and I feel you know
very lucky about that.
I never really thought of music
as a way of creating a platform
for myself as an individual artist.
I never thought that
someday I'm going
to have my own band
and my own records.
I mean, eventually that happened and
it's been a great experience too.
But I usually measure in terms
of our very small,
little jazz world here.
I measure musicians sort of in terms
of who they play with, you know.
And if I see a musician who's
playing with a whole bunch
of different people, I think, "Okay,
so that guy must be good, you know."
He's respected in the
community and he's first call
for these different projects.
So they must have something
that all these musicians
from different places
are attracted to.
So I feel that as I get to play
with more musicians and I get
to be more experienced,
I feel good about that.
You know, more than anything
else, that I have that kind
of connection to the community.
>> Larry Applebaum: That's it.
You must be good.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, again, think
about your questions.
But you know, I couldn't help but
notice you have your horn with you.
Yes, right behind the chair.
I wonder if you could be persuaded
to let that bad boy out of the case.
[ Applause ]
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Questions first?
>> Miguel Zenon: Maybe we
do the questions first.
>> AL: Okay.
Who has a question?
There's one right there.
>> I had a question for
all of us amateur musicians
about how you encourage people to be
willing to take the chance to get up
and play in front of other people.
>> Miguel Zenon: Well you know,
that takes some courage for sure,
especially if you're
just getting started
and if you haven't
had the experience.
But I feel like it's
like anything, you know?
As you gain confidence
in what you're doing,
and that was my experience,
you know, the more I practiced
and the more I felt that
I could do something
with a certain amount of comfort.
It became a little
easier to get up on stage
and play in front of people.
Of course, the first time
I did it I was terrified.
And the second time a little less,
and the third time a little less.
And it kind of goes like that.
I've been doing this
for a long time.
Still, once in a while you know,
I'll get a little something.
Maybe it's a family member in
the audience or someone I admire,
so I'm getting really jitterish.
But after a while if you do it
enough, it just becomes routine.
It just becomes something
that you're comfortable with.
>> AL: Who else?
There is one right there.
>> Thank you so much for being here.
[Inaudible].
I first saw you 20 years
ago performing at --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Miguel Zenon: So David
and I, we actually went
to the same performing arts school
in Puerto Rico, the [Spanish name].
He went there -- he's about
eight years older than I am.
So he was there way before me
and I didn't meet him
at the school of course.
But we went through
the same courses.
We had the same saxophone
teacher and everything, you know.
And of course when I was at the
school, when I was finishing up
and getting into jazz, he was kind
of like putting out first records.
So I was a great admirer of his work
like when I was just
getting started.
Eventually once I moved to
Boston I got really close
with another Latin American
musician, Danilo Perez.
He was a pianist and composer.
And Danilo sort of
became a mentor in Boston.
You know, I spent a lot of time with
him and would go off to his house,
take lessons, play with him a bunch.
So I met David through Danilo
while I was still in Boston.
I still remember when I met him.
We met at this place for dinner and
then David was playing that night.
I came over and I sat in and
played with him and it was cool.
And then eventually when I
started figuring out what to do
after school, after Berkeley,
some folks suggested,
"You should go to New York."
I thought, "Okay, maybe
I'll try that."
I had family in New York so
that made sense at the time.
I was going to school in New York.
And when I was in New York,
the first thing I did
was I called up David.
You know, I was like,
"I'm in New York.
Remember we met in Boston?"
And David did basically
exactly the same thing
that Danilo did, you know.
I would go over to his house
and he became a mentor.
I would go over to
his house like, "Man,
I'm kind of playing on this tune.
Do you think you hear another line?"
He was like, "Maybe I
hear a counter line."
And I started doing
that just for fun.
And then it was like, "You know, we
should play that at the gig tonight.
Why don't you come over?"
And I went and played.
And we did that in Boston.
It was like, "Why don't
you come on tour?"
I did that and started
playing with him.
The relationship was born
out of that sort of dynamic.
And just kind of going back to
this idea of David and Danilo,
they're very close friends and they
both played together for a long time
with [inaudible] and a
bunch of other bands.
And to me, when I started
getting into jazz,
they represented what
I wanted to achieve,
not in terms of success or anything.
But I felt that as working musicians
they have both been able to get
to a place where they can be
respected as jazz musicians,
you know, authentic jazz musicians.
But at the same time,
represent their culture, right?
In the case of David and Danilo,
they are both very connected
to you know, the music
of the country and trying
to represent that in their music.
And I related to that idea
very deeply, you know.
And I related to the idea of making
music that wasn't just sound.
Sort of like instrumental
dance music kind of thing,
but that had more of a
balance between what I consider
to be essential elements of
jazz, interaction, you know,
this idea of taking risk and
letting things kind of flow.
And combining that with
folklore and all this.
And I felt the music at the time
represented that, and that was kind
of what I was trying to achieve.
So it was really nice to cross paths
with them and eventually you know,
become part of their
little circle in a way.
So that was really great.
Thank you.
>> Larry Applebaum: Who
else has a question?
We have a question in the front row.
You have a question?
Do you want to come ask?
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
It can be Spanish.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Great question.
>> Miguel Zenon: She asks
who made the decision
that I was going to
become a decision.
So I made that decision myself,
but it was a hard decision
because at first I wasn't sure.
I was like, "Maybe I
should do something else."
I wanted to be an engineer.
I wanted to study science and math.
You know, I was interested
in that as well.
But I really loved music
and I really loved to play.
So I said, "I'm going to give
it a try and see how it goes.
And then if after a couple
years it doesn't feel good,
maybe I'll go to the other thing."
It felt good after a couple
years, so I said, "Okay,
I'll give it a couple more years."
And then eventually I just kept
going and it became what I do.
Okay?
>> Larry Applebaum: Can you
say what you love about music?
>> Miguel Zenon: You know, when
I first started playing music
and not necessarily playing
jazz, but playing an instrument,
I liked the fact that it
felt like a game to me.
I remember when I was playing
music, I was also playing a lot
of basketball at the time.
And it felt the same way to me.
It was almost like
something you do for fun.
You can interact with others.
You can portray your
personality, be competitive
and do things to make
yourself better.
And even though I've been doing it
for a long time, I still try to find
that sort of like childlike
mentality where you just do it
because it's fun and playful.
>> Larry Applebaum: Beautiful.
Who else has a question?
No? Well maybe now's the time.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
We want to hear him.
>> Larry Applebaum: Yeah.
Let's see what happens.
>> Miguel Zenon: Let me see.
[ Applause ]
[ Playing jazz music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.